this video is for language teachers if
you don't know who I am my name is
Blossom I use they them pronouns in
English
I'm an educational consultant for gender
and sexuality and I specifically did my
research on transgender people's
attitudes towards pronoun usage and
their native and additional languages
and this is me telling you that within
whatever language you speak non-binary
people exist and non-binary people are
creating language that they don't have
to adhere to the gender binary so we as
language teachers need to be teaching
our students giving our students access
to this language especially for our
non-binary students regardless of if
that language is accepted by a
linguistic regulatory body hey y'all
this is
is that what we need to be doing that's
what we need to be doing yeah that's
what that's what people need more than
anything they don't need food or
medicine or fresh water you know we need
the inclusive pronouns the pronouns when
is when did this pronouns should even
become a thing this is new this isn't
all past few years yeah it's been a few
years so stupid yeah this is your daily
reminder that Dr Seuss is racist
my daily reminder out of all the stuff I
could be reminded of every day thank you
brother that Dr Seuss is racist I almost
forgot I remembered yesterday but today
I I almost forgot so thank you in your
classroom I get that some of these books
are considered Classics I mean I grew up
on them myself I also get that he was a
product of his time but also mind you
this is 2021 there are literally so many
other books that are more inclusive to
all students that you can use instead
I've heard a lot of people say that
gender is complex and sex is simple as a
biology teacher I highly disagree gender
is really easy gender is how someone
identifies it so just listen to them
when they tell you if they're male
female or non-binary sex is more complex
biology teachers like to boil it down to
XX and X Y but there are so many more
combinations than not of the sex
chromosomes also that is only
chromosomal sex it's not biological sex
in its in fired it there's really only
one gene on the Y chromosome the sry
gene that contributes to the production
of traditional male hormones it could be
chromosomally male but that Gene could
be inactivated this is it these ideas no
but I did some reading about this and I
would like to actually I wish I had it
handy are you a scientist guy because
these are chromosomal uh abnormal their
abnormalities their anomalies they're
extremely extremely rare they want us to
all just bow down to this this one
particular person this is again your
analogy like why don't we all just cut
off or cut off our legs so that people
without legs feel good about themselves
like that's not good that doesn't help
anybody so this woman trying to teach
people in her smug way about this isn't
helping isn't helping these people
because we're all sick of it Gene could
have translocated to an X chromosome and
is now present in a chromosomal female
those are just two examples there are so
many different possibilities biology
teachers please expand what you're
teaching so our students know how
complex this is and how rare it is don't
forget the Rarity of it
what the [__]
this has been my first year in preschool
test I'm sorry I know I'm trying to be
nice here but Jesus I've had it I have
had it they are poisoning kids Minds I'm
telling you I had teachers like this
like that you a lot of the stuff some of
the stuff we watch it's like okay this
is an abnormality people make a much
bigger deal out of it than it has to be
like yeah it's crazy but it's not the
end of the world with this [__] I saw it
firsthand I literally saw it with my own
eyes where they were shoving this [__]
down our throat in school it's crazy
this is not made up I'm sure I'm sure
you're sick of it you're a bigot no not
a big
science Andrew Tates the devil the devil
teaching alongside another queer
neurodivergent educator and we have been
rocking our two's class we've been
talking about gender and skin color and
consent and empathy and our bodies and
autonomy everybody you get a label you
get a label you get a label you get a
label you want more labels you can have
20 labels go ahead I'll just give you
all the labels you want because that
makes you feel special because you can't
accomplish anything because you're so
stuck in your head about how you feel
about your boobies wouldn't want to wake
up now she's been rocking it though
she's so proud of herself confusing kids
about the most basic things in their
lives yes making them completely
self-centered me me me me monsters
but our thinking team is Shifting and a
new person is being onboarded someone
with many years of experience so today
at the lunch table when the topic of
gender and genitals came up one of our
students plainly looked up and said well
I'm a girl today but I know that teacher
Co isn't no they're envy and the look on
the incoming teacher's face was
priceless she she was shocked in a good
way and she just looked around at the
two of us and said this class was
incredible and I am so impressed
[Music]
and if I give
the indoctrination is real man
it's crazy
that's crazy you were that excited over
there
it's whatever I'm just keep going how
come how come we don't do this with
other mental illnesses how come we're
like oh ladies and gentlemen I just boys
and girls I mean excuse me
um grade tours uh I'd just like you to
know that we have a schizophrenic over
here and an anorexic over here and a
bulimic everybody it just let's make
sure that we address them according to
their mental illness today
let's just do that let's just start
doing that
or my own children and they die
how am I gonna live with them
and I want you to ask any teacher
how they feel this year and I'm sure
that they will tell you that they have
never experienced anxiety like this
because it is like we are trying to
protect our students from a mass
shooting that we know is coming but
cannot do anything about except we can
do something about it it's just that not
everyone agrees that wearing a mask will
stop the onslaught of students and staff
who are likely to become sick and that
makes me sick what did she just say did
she just about masking yeah it went from
shootings to masks no she used shootings
as an analogy yeah I get that but like
sweet tits but it was but to come on
that's a ridiculous analogy they kill
the grandmas they hit you with the
emotions this is what the left does they
grab your heart and they're like if you
don't wear your mask you're not even a
real man because a real man would want
to save the grandmas you want grandmas
to die they do this with every little
thing climate change oh you don't like
the [__] polar bears you want your
grandkids to grow up in [__] Sea
World when the world's underwater they
they do this with everything and it's
all [__] they're good at it though
they're propaganda Masters I'll give it
to the I'll give it to the top of the
left they're good propaganda Masters
they do a good job at it because they
pay out they pay the media as a branding
and the marketing expert I I acknowledge
it I acknowledge that they do a very
good job like if you look at even like
the fact Checkers under posts they're
there by branding teams like you said to
look as factual as possible and the way
you're taught to see things as fact it's
to analyze something like that like the
fact checked her under a post and be
like this is facts but it's not and it
wasn't even and they knew they knew
there were holes in those facts about
mask efficacy early on yeah but like and
yet and now they're only admitting that
it was a bunch of horseshit imagine if
you if you if this if this virus was
truly that deadly to the point where if
someone had their mask down people were
dying you think you would actually be in
school if you think you would actually
be in school if it was like a simple it
was literally a matter of like like if
my mask goes below my nose we're dead
you're that brainwashed it's crazy I
remember being in school and I was like
questioning my teachers I was like even
my science teacher so I was like bro is
it really that important we wear these
masks like is this is ridiculous and
he's like well you know like spit
particles could fly out and spread the
virus technically and it's like bro are
we gonna like like micro analyze like
literally everything like if it's like a
population of young boys who are at
their peak of Health it's like 16 17
year old boys yeah and then they hit you
with the grandma's thing because they
know that they gotta attack emotions if
you use them with anyone and then if you
live with your grandma and you're not
afraid how about you just stay home and
you just keep wiping down your grocery
bags wipe your grocery bags buddy you'll
be all right it's not gonna get you stay
home don't build any immunity do you
remember how also after kovid people
shut themselves off from viruses so much
that everyone got sick when stuff opened
up yeah I was sick for like two months
because you're just not around germs and
now I'm drinking like raw milk raw eggs
I'm just like drinking if there's like a
puddle I'll drink out of it I don't give
a [__] it's germs and it's like good for
you though [__] builds you up better
than medicine Haram it's all poison yeah
you're absolutely right and you know
what not for nothing but you need some
mental germs too you need some mental
toughness too we have our our we've
created the Society of people where they
have no emotional immunity to anything
and every single thing post worms into
their brain like a disease look at that
teacher look at how she was just like
hysterically crying actually crying
jokes you're emotionally unstable and
shouldn't be in a room full of children
running the show it's legit jokes like
we need emotional immunity we really
need to to explain to people who are
weak-minded that they can be strong
people need some these people need to be
of stronger mind it's a choice people
need some top G that's what they need
hand sanitizer is for [__] somebody
with a strong mind that that they relate
to whether it's top three or something
one of the things that I've learned a
lot about in the past couple years is
discipline get control of your head
control your mind and learn discipline
and so you stop talking yourself out of
things and so you know Tom Shea the Navy
SEAL who we work with I went through his
21 day challenge where he gave me some
tasks to do every day and part of the
challenge was to wake up every day
commit to doing it and every time I
started to talk myself out of it I would
have an excuse run through my head some
lame ass excuse and there are four main
excuses that he teaches people that are
that ruin lives that's why we're doing
the 21 Day Challenge again together
which Sunny is not excited about because
he's going to have Tom on his ass if you
guys actually would like to do that with
us go to the link in the description
because there's a discount code come and
do it because guaranteed in one area of
your life there's something you're not
doing because you talk yourself out of
it every day you can go to the top of
the description click the link and buy
it with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing it with you
guys we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool again for those
in the back road
CRT is not being taught below law school
those of you that are against it are
being misled by the media about what's
and where and when it is taught what
you're really against is the 1619
project so start calling it what it is
you are against us teaching the true
history of this country and on
whitewashing the curriculum no we're
against where what we are against is
teaching everything through the that
that everything that exists is a result
of white supremacy and is still being
controlled by white supremacists that is
what we are against nutcase get her off
I don't want to look at her again oh God
you've got another one she's got another
new one I don't want to watch this one
anymore all in classrooms she's so small
and obnoxious
today is the first time our country a
little Tick Tock tip you typically want
to go for like you know one to twenty
for the likes to comments she had a good
one to two so
you know it says something about the
video yes recognized Juneteenth
it's national holiday and yet I'm
getting ready to go back to school in
the fall
and my Governor has put into place some
ridiculous legislation that many
Governors across the country have put
into place such as I can't teach
anything divisive
I can't teach critical race Theory and I
can't teach about racial Equity this
isn't all public
schools colleges and universities
so teachers
in the past
we've been activists after this show of
last year we really need to stand up and
do what's right for our kids right now
so this is a call to action teachers
we got to stand up and fight for our
kids because this is [__] do your
students call you by your first name or
Mr or Miss great question this is
actually a classic question here's your
answer currently my students just call
me Desmond or Desi first name however I
have been at schools that go by last
name those schools I go by teacher
fambrini I am gender fluid so I don't go
by Mr or meth I go by teacher because I
am a teacher so Desmond Desi or teacher
fambrini I'm starting to get a little
emotional is that okay or is that too
gender specific because you that that
twice implies that you're male if I call
you son Sunny Creator Elena
laughs thank you thank you very thing
person Elena Creator my dad's I called
my I'll call my dad Creator and I'll
call you birthing person birthing person
Mom oh
looking at
the new masks I got for a couple reasons
I got a bunch of just plain ones but
my Governor is doing nothing about covid
I have co-workers that have 42 students
in their class this year
I because I teach self-contained special
education my classes are more at 18 or
20 which is still pretty big when
this pandemic's going on
um so boring
you know
our governor has not only said that a
report if you have covid you don't have
to quarantine W Governor anything black
lives dreams and Futures match except I
like to repeat whenever I get a chance
the 20 million black babies that have
been killed since Roe v Wade went into
effect so that's 20 million chances of
new branches of black families seeds
that were starved of water and sunlight
and the opportunity to thrive so stop
with your black lives matter [__]
because it's a lie you don't really care
okay some Flags put up in every
classroom we're gonna have to say the
Pledge of Allegiance and
I'm not going to be able to talk about
basically any of the things
that I have on these masks I need the
things that matter to you personally you
can't talk about at your job yeah you're
at your job there's nothing to do with
your job keep it to your Twitter reading
no followers arithmetic science isn't
that what they're supposed to be
teaching not my personal ideology I'm
not able to teach you all the things
that matter to me yeah I I go if I when
I had jobs I went to the job and I had
to do What mattered to the company if
I'm teaching I'm not you know when if I
was a teacher I'd want to teach about
you know getting hoes hey little Timmy
this is how you get some hoes but I
can't teach that because it's not the
curriculum unless that's what you were
hired to teach if I'm tired if I'm tired
to teach you how to get hoes then that's
what I would teach right
makes sense exactly on these masks
you want to like always talk when I
start the video I know it just happens
every single time I start the video
it's like a woodpecker yeah
non-binary alpaca
the kids voted on the gender-neutral
name Alex for them Alex was there to
help me during the really quiet moments
when nobody would talk during virtual
learning yes they were so quiet but then
I also took a grown man opportunity to
teach my students about how to respect
people's pronouns did Alex ever get
misgendered
yes but then it opened up some teachable
moments about what to do and that would
happen for example hey Mr Moon did he
just wake up from his nap
or do you mean that they wake up from
their nap yeah they just did
would apologize quickly make the
correction and move on I started off
modeling how to make kids apologize for
calling that thing up the wrong gender
you make kids say I am sorry
I am sorry because I didn't gender your
your toy wrong your puppet because I
misgendered a puppet this is like this
man is like the teacher of like 30 kids
for a whole year that's CR it's crazy
that's legit crazy somebody and then
afterwards my students would correct
each other whenever somebody with
misgender Alex here representation in
the classroom matters my kids were fifth
graders and they still got a kick out of
Alex okay so here's the thing
is my pronouns he him at first my
students thought that he had very
feminine features so they thought that
he was a girl and this is why we should
never assume somebody's gender just
based on what they look like all right
when you can say something hello my
students were really surprised how low
his voice sounded don't assume okay so
he he's got he's he had to bring in a
puppet to make the point about gender
neutral pronouns because there isn't
even anyone in the classroom that is is
gender neutral because it's not real
life that this is that common so we're
going to pretend we're going to make
everything forced for circles and
squares and teach kids about [__] that
doesn't actually even ever that they're
probably never going to run into in the
real life once this fad of social
contagion is over it's crazy
all right that was fun okay thank you
Creator thank you Creator mom for
watching this with me and thank you all
for watching this as well make sure to
like if you enjoyed the video subscribe
follow me on Instagram at Sunny Faz and
I will see you all later
[Music]